pas de chèque carburant ont versé par la
région bourgogne franche comté à ses
habitants pour compenser l'augmentation
des prix à la pompe
si la présidente marie-guite dufay dit
comprendre le ras-le-bol des français la
région préfère miser sur le
développement durable la responsabilité
de la région c'est de faire en sorte que
demain
et bien il y à un réflexe pour moins
utiliser sa voiture
cela pour des questions de préservation
de l'environnement et nous nous
engageons effectivement avec ce qu'avec
notre démarche de moby go nous puissions
dans un an
faire une proposition extrêmement
précises à tous les habitants de
bourgogne et de franche-comté pour
qu'ils aient de la mobilité de proximité
organisée pour eux par la région un
service de covoiturage qui devrait voir
le jour à l'automne prochain tout comme
la gratuité totale dans les transports
scolaires
pas suffisant pour les groupes
d'opposition le rassemblement national
qui soutient le mouvement des gilet
jaune est favorable à un dispositif
similaire à celui en vigueur dans les
hauts de france ou déposeront un voeu
pour la création d'un chèque régional
l'aide à la mobilité donc de 50 euros
par mois pour les habitants des
territoires ruraux qui n'ont pas d'autre
possibilité que d'utiliser leur voiture
puisqu'on sait très bien que il ya de
nombreux territoires comme l'yonne comme
la nièvre comme la haute saône où les
habitants sont tributaires de leur
véhicule pour aller travailler un voeu
qui a peu de chances d'aboutir d'autant
que comme la majorité régionale la
droite et le centre ne sont pas
favorables à l'idée d'un chèque
carburant et préconisent d'autres
options je regrettais que la région
n'affiche pas plus franchement son
soutien à la voiture à hydrogène il faut
trouver des moyens alternatifs pour
permettre précisément d'avoir des des
énergies décarbonées et de répondre aux
nécessités de ce changement climatique
et la région un rôle à jouer
prix du carburant et pouvoir d'achat
s'invite donc bien ce jeudi dans
l'hémicycle régional lors du débat
d'orientation budgétaire de mi mandat
la présence de jeu plaisant